data showing how behind nevada is when  it comes to the covid vaccinations we  have received the second  lowest number of doses per capita out of  all states so far  the governor sent a letter to the  national health and human services  secretary  regarding our allocation candice  mcdaniel with the nevada department of  health and human services  says we should be seeing more doses of  moderna and pfizer arriving  the mass vaccination operations that we  are setting up  need the predictability to keep going it  doesn't make sense to open for a few  days  and then close for a few because we run  out of vaccines  as for long-term care and for skilled  nursing facilities vaccines are still  ongoing the state is making sure  that these facilities are accounted for  and that doses are readily available  denise